I can't believe we've come to the end of the show.
Ruby, did you have a favorite part today?
You know, the entire day was my favorite,
but I do have one small favorite piece.
It was when Adam sang happy birthday to me.
(gasping) I mean, hello.
I mean, I had chills,
chills, I couldn't believe it.
Hello, bucket list, check.
Yeah.
Yeah, yes.
That was, that was really special.
It was.
Like we've all heard Happy Birthday, our entire lives.
He put a whole new spin on it
But Adam Lambert, the best, the best.
Well, thank you, Ruby.
(audience applauding)
It was so much fun.
Thank you for having me,
thank you so much for having me.
It was so fun to do the show with you.
We wanted to give you something for all your great work,
so we are literally making you our employee of the month.
Is that what that says?
(audience cheering)
Oh my god!
(audience applauding)
That is so cute, I love it!
I can't believe it, oh my god!
But much more importantly,
we're gonna send you and a friend off
to the Sandbar Rooftop in Manhattan for dinner,
this amazing place that's outdoors, cocktails,
sophisticated menu, and amazing views of the city.
And we just would like to buy you some cocktails and food
and have an evening on us.
Yes, thank you!
(audience applauding)
Oh my gosh, thanks so much!
(audience cheering)
Thank you all so much for being here.
We make this show for you.
So we hope that you can take this with you
and the good energy and everything.
And just thank you for choosing to spend your time with us.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(uplifting music)